[Musik]
meine Kniescheibe Adam technisch gebaut für
Person C Hollanders für MRI tan Hände
E-Mail war Manoah im Fernsehen bei Sue's Act
hatte Umstand unter einer Lagune Sri Sri
Ravi Shankar ist spiritueller
Alehrer Freiheitssport Floß auf geläppten Forbes in einem
der betonten und rätselhaften Indianer
auf der CES gezeigt  und Sri Sri hat ein Schwein
in der Nähe der Spiritualität ergriffen, die Anfänger
Vanneman Z für Hagen VM und East verkauft,
die anderen in C, befehlen Sie mir, da
selbst ein Frosch die Rechte gemeinsam hat,
ist dies die grundlegende Frage, die uns hilft,
herauszufinden, wer wir wirklich sind
und sobald wir feststellen, dass wir nicht nur
unsere Gedanken oder Emotionen sind, sondern etwas
mehr als das, das Bewusstsein,
wissen sie, dass es uns eine solche innere Stärke verleiht,
dass wir unser Lächeln nicht auf kleine
Dinge um uns herum verlieren, in einem gewissen Detail
personalisiert, denke ich, so ist das  was ich in der
Lage bin, dies anderen namens
Menagerie Sri Ravi Shankar über Sri Sri
Sri beizubringen, und sogar die
Kondommanifestation von noch einer weiteren Doppler-
Träne über Sri Sri hoch  lagern Sie zuerst meinen
Schreibtisch, wissen Sie, sobald sie für
alle in Indien da ist, ist sie zu sehen, die
Art von Ehre,
tatsächlich Leute stellen drei vier auf
zweihundert Bäume nebeneinander, dachte, es ist genug
Gedanke, mehr als zwei halten
Neiman auch diesen Whitney für Neiman
Zivilist diese sind in den Kondomen und
ich werde halten Schwester Handy ja von
der Gesellschaft von den Leuten okay
wenn göttlicher Mann ich bin sicher, er hatte das
nötige und ihr Haar Shankar
ja okay Aleve wegen drei bedeutet
Reverend ehrenwert ja ja a  etwas
mehr
, um einen leAndria-Stich hinzuzufügen, auch Wien,
Peshawar, Geographie, traf Filmwissenschaftler auf
meinem Meditationssarg, in was und
Illyricum, also noch weiter, tatsächlich
passieren, Shanti Bhagavad-Gita, eine weitere
Auflistung über zentrale Intuition, Verschiebung,
bereit, Träne und Kanone, Yoga, Killian,
Meeresfrüchte, gut Scheiße  hatte seine Herrschaft, aber
da das System Tanzkanal der
Hindu Moses Kreise ist, ja, Hinduismus im Grunde
die Lebensweise, also war für mich Philosophie
wie Fisch im Wasser, es war sehr einfach  sy für
mich, obwohl ich Naturwissenschaften studiert habe, war
Philosophie immer
sehr kalt in meinem Leben, also habe ich einfach weiter
mein Wissen mit anderen geteilt, dann wurde
ich Lehrer, es war nur ein
Zufall. Ich würde mich
als zufälligen Lehrer bezeichnen  mmm im
Grunde war mein Interesse an der Wissenschaft in
der Konzentration von Irlands Männern sind
nur zwei Nobelpreisauslöser
Rabindranath Tagore für Instant-Wüsten
Sie sind Touristen, die Xiang hilft, eine
Philosophie oder Kunst zu erzwingen, die
uns aus den Sitzen treibt
Bürgerlicher Guru Das Ende des Krieges
Ja, wie ich schon sagte, Sie wissen, dass ich ER nicht ausspioniert habe
, um Lehrer zu werden, aber ich war
in meiner Kindheit von vielen Lehrern umgeben. Mein
erster Lehrer war einer, der es war Mahatma
Gandhi für 40 Jahre lehrte er Mathe meine
Zuckertüte  mit Gita und Sadaqa/Wohltätigkeit,
also sind wir mit Geschichten von einem großartigen
Mann und Matt, meinem Gandhi und Tiger, aufgewachsen, also war das
Wertesystem damals sehr stark,
und dann traf ich viele spirituelle Führer a  Zu
dieser Zeit mm-hmm und all die segensreichen
Einflüsse waren immer bei
mir auf samtigem und sprudelndem TV-Stick, immer noch
hier, huh, Salmoniden, Mahatma Gandhi, was
ist meine Mutter,
ah, Asset, ist nicht in Gilead, oh, meine Mutter
hat ihm alles beigebracht, einschließlich auf
Reena zu spielen  das instrument ah ja musikinstrumente
da huang musica tatsu lg
omnia noms feta ravi shankar aber er war
aus dem norden und aus dem süden nur ein
südindisches instrument sehr ähnlich zu
sita
das heißt reena ja und damit war
auch meine mutter sehr gut  in
Sanskrit zärtlich also die Mutter und dann mussten
wir es so dr ausgeben.  Chaturvedi,
er ist hundertachtzehn Jahre alt,
wie Sie wissen, ja, Stella, und
dann verbrachte ich einige Zeit mit Marcia
Mahesh Yogi hier in der Schweiz. Auch
Polly ist in ernsthafter Gefahr, da er die epische
Kantate 30 transzendental c1 imitiert,
dann die Serien Parks und Caesar, aber
Schnellfeuer Yahoo  Das Fernsehen ist intensiv, kasam
Tora,
ja, ja, ich kam, um Vorträge über vedisches Wissen zu halten,
weil ich vedisches Wissen studiert hatte
Interesse war auch Wissenschaft und
auch am Veda, also hatten wir früher einige
Seminare dort ja
Vaska jetzt fürchte deine Vision Schaffhausen
schau verrate sie nicht gerne
Zwanziger sind in der Wissenschaft Ich sage, ich habe
Physik, Chemie und Mathematik studiert, ja,
lass uns Pucon folgen, ja
[Gelächter]
außer Maharishi Opie, aber sehr freundlich
, dass das kein verschwommenes Verschwinden hinterlassen hat, seien Sie
versichert, dass ich Javon Zeriba Lehrer
und Bama Lin bin  dsey leaseback reife
Fragmentierung nein Ich war für kurze
Zeit hier, als ich mit den
Wissenschaftlern dort diskutierte, wo früher Wissenschaftler
aus verschiedenen Teilen der Welt kamen, dann war ich,
wie Sie wissen, Vorträge zu halten und
vedische Wissenschaft über Ventilatoren in
Elbe-Limousinen für den Dissing-Guru Govardhan zu studieren
es gibt eine anstandslücke unsere schuld ich
sehe passieren menschen fürchten millionen eine nonne hänger
ich als ich nach indien ging dann nahm ich
es 1981 am tag der stille mm-hmm 82
damals nach der elektromotorischen stille
fing ich an die atemtechniken zu
unterrichten ja alles  Am deutlichsten
animierend, nein Hayden,
ja, diese Atemtechnik wurde so
beliebt und die Menschen mussten jede Welle
lernen, damit uns fast 350
Millionen Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
beigebracht wurden, die diese weiteren Vorfälle lernen mussten,
laden uns zur Erweiterung von NG und
Gurus ein  und die C-Legierungen, die senden,
wenn du erkennst, dass das Zentrum deines
Seins alles ist, was es
Erleuchtung genannt hat, fühle ich, dass es in
jedem ist  Ein reines Herz, ein
klarer Geist, Aufrichtigkeit in Aktion, das
kommt ganz natürlich aus dir heraus, und ob
du es Erleuchtung oder totales
Bewusstsein oder Klarheit der Weisheit nennst oder das
Leben in eine andere Dimension von totalem Frieden
und Harmonie bringst, ich würde sagen,
seit Indiana ist es egal  prominente familie wurde
quasi als mutterschaftspfarrer gecastet ein
benutzerdefinierter odom es kinesins hier im indischen
channahon spezialist motor der
gewaltigen it's the super hop-think aber
leistung und guru in ihram xena asana
unter und werfen einen kommentar weiter ja ja
ja ja gurus sind da  Von allen Autos ist
dies in der indischen Geschichte vorhanden. Wenn Sie
das 12. Jahrhundert sehen, gibt es viele
Heilige, die von allen Autos zur niedrigsten
Kaste gehören  Markierung gemietet für ihren eigenen
unterschiedlichen astok Sie wissen, ja über
Jungfrauen Eden's Arden trifft uns gerne
hier Lager Mann fühlt Essig Vibe Alicia
Gurus wie geistig er Gurus es dir gesagt hat  s oder
ästhetisch so auf Venedig August wie die
Hölle am besten, also gibt es hier keine weiblichen
Gurus und Essig wird Mann können keine
Berghütten dir versichern, dass sie keine
Gurus können männlich weiblich sein, jeder um
jeden Preis, es gibt keine Bar dafür, sich daran zu
halten  Sehen Sie, Sie denken, es ist wie jemand mit
einer Expertise in Bezug auf Bewusstsein
, der Menschen helfen kann und der
bedingungslose Liebe hat, als was für ein Guru ich sein
kann, aus jeder Art, aus jeder Klasse, aus
jedem Geschlecht, es ist absolut absolut kein
Vorurteil oder Voreingenommenheit, was das angeht
Der Stamm kann sich auch so anfühlen, als ob er mir gehört. Sie
sehen, wie jemand darin gesprochen hat. Ich
kann auch die Stimmung spüren, die ein romantischer Co-Moderator
oder ein Inder hat
Stellenangebote sind verfügbar
mehr Leute sollten heraufkommen, sie
verstand von Anfang an, dass er sagte - ähm
ja, nach Stipendien und Bereich einen Fühler sehen
und eine neue Person aufhängen, die nur eine
Person genau über Todd kennt, fragt
Lao NK, behandelte sie nicht einmal
hübsch, aber
tut er Spiritualität beim Committee on
Indian Nick no Indians sogar cosa
ungeschlagen Sunderland MGR Venedig
produktiv eine Kolumne die Hobbys Musik von
Arced ist diese Art von a - Paul Anka
Köche, um einen Guru Tzu's zu kleben, ich bin ja
für jede Institution
da  Damit ein
Bild da ist, braucht man einen
Rahmen, um das Bild so zu halten. Um
Wissen zu verbreiten, braucht man etwas
Organisation und für die Organisation hat
einen Teil davon Finanzen, also sind wir
in I Rita,
unsere Organisation ist vollständig  Gewicht davon
oder bildete junge Leute für die Ausbildung von Fähigkeiten aus.
Wir schaffen Arbeitsplätze für sie. Wir haben
eine Universität. Wir haben Schulen
kommt sauber die Wunde hoch und zidler
der unbekümmerte Deutsche sein cooles Zeug über das
Geschehene von verdächtigen Kuriositäten und
verschämten Hoheiten und besucht
natürlich den gebildeten Josh Ravin
m  Verwaltung Sehen Sie, Sophia hat keine
Exzentrizität in der Währung. Ich habe
nie eine Warteliste. Wer also gewöhnlich ist, es ist
einfach, nichts zu tun und
friedlich zu sein. Es ist schwieriger,
friedlich zu sein, obwohl sie die
Verantwortung für das ganze
Weltthema in Tavares übernimmt  409 Neuling über uns
Martin Sedum Ganske jetzt Jahr im Kongress
ein Statistiker Cuttino mm also wer rührt
und ECT ow Ich bin Shelly mein Tagesablauf
ist das Ich bin morgens alleine
Ich weißt du, für mich findet Meditation den
ganzen Tag statt, aber
Was immer ich tue, ich tue für die Menschen auf dem
Weltplaneten, ich möchte
jedem ein Lächeln ins Gesicht zaubern und ich denke immer darüber nach, wie
ich der Gesellschaft nützlicher sein kann, und
jeden Abend verbrachte ich etwas Zeit mit Musik,
die wir Satsang nennen, und mit Menschen, die wir alle sind
Beim Singen zusammenkommen Ich hatte einige
Fragen, Antworten, einige Weisheiten, ja,
ein Leben aus einer breiteren Perspektive zu
sehen, und Eloy sieht die Synthese jedes Gerichts
und die Umsetzung von kastanienbraunen Skianzügen, einen
emeritierten Stich von tw  Itter
Angie um Angst Millionen oder Tamia
Anhänger sehen hängend gefallen Neiman Woche
zumindest leicht Asymmetrie geworden t Die
Frage war, ob ich einer Person folge,
es ist nicht gerecht für andere,
also wem ich folgen kann, du weißt, wenn du
einer folgst, dann gebe ich
Sonderbehandlung für eine Person, der ich
jemandem folge, entweder ich folge allen
vier Millionen, ich folge ihnen, also entscheide ich mich dafür
, die Ehre als Annika HT zu halten, transferiere
wieder, du hast Autismus in meiner Position, ich
muss
für jeden glauben, er sagte, wir seien reich oder
arm  Berühmt oder berüchtigt, wie sie auch sein mögen,
und ich habe
mein ganzes Leben lang behauptet, dass in unserer Saison
unser 450-Gramm-Kokon der Art of Living
Foundation passieren soll, der eine Flagge im
Osten von Suez besaß und eine wirklich
coole Sonne von Viacom besaß  Ein
Zionist, den Sie nicht kennen. Das Ziel der Stiftung
ist es, den Menschen klar zu machen, dass das Leben ein
Fest ist, und Glück in
das Leben aller zu bringen. Dafür haben wir
alle alten Techniken zur
Verfügung gestellt, um sie zu modernisieren  ople die Alta tecnica
Minenstadt unsere Versuchung Exsudation Korea
heute
gut Emu Kojoten sind technisch gesehen in
Spaltung und haben auch viele Bewegungskommerzialisierung
jedes Geräusch jetzt ja nein,
aber Sie wissen, dass es bestimmte Dinge
gibt, von denen bestimmte Dinge nicht jedem bekannt waren,
war jetzt ein stinkender Lärm
Wenn Sie dies tun,
ist Sudarshan Kriya dieses Atemmuster, das
tiefer geht und unsere Emotionen reinigt,
Sie sich von innen sehr frisch fühlen lässt
und Sie in eine tiefere Meditation
bringt  Deshalb nenne ich
das Aus dem Leben und Tabu durch das
Tabu ist, dass die Leute immer noch Mainstream-Leute vor
vierzig Jahren nicht mit Yoga angefangen haben. Ja,
sie dachten, wenn Sie Yoga machen,
müssen Sie irgendwo da draußen sein, also
sagten wir, dass diese Leute Kunst des Lebens sind  Es
sprach jeden an
, und obwohl es etwas Yoga und
Meditation oder einfach nur Yoga hatte, sprach es auch
über das Leben, das Leben aus einem breiteren
Bild und Medit zu sehen  Das alles hat
den Menschen geholfen, sich zu integrieren, also hat
es den Menschen geholfen,
aus der Depression herauszukommen
Steuern Sie
keine Hoffnung, ich kann mich nicht ärgern, dass Maha
Yoga Führer hält, die Kieselsäure besitzen.
Sie haben Ideen zu Lichtern in jedem Vers,
sehen jedoch CentOS und Notfallmission auf dem Bildschirm,
oder derzeit sage ich,
dass es ein reifes Jahrzehnt ist, in dem die
Kunstbewegung endet  Oh nein, du weißt, Atmen
kannst du nicht so zeigen, aber es gibt eine
Reihe von Atemtechniken, nicht nur
eine, sondern Sudarshan
Kriya  Davor gibt es eine
Vorbereitung, die Sie brauchen, um die dreistufige
Atmung zu machen, wissen Sie, tut mir leid, ich rufe hier nicht an
, ja, von der tieferen Atmung aus
dem Bauch, von der Brust und und
über einen Teil des Pa  Sobald Sie dies tun
, atmen Sie im Rhythmus, und das
wissen Sie wirklich, öffnet die Tür für
tiefere spirituelle Erfahrungen. Dieser
Vorfall, die Hälfte der TC-Technik,
Sie wissen, wie ich
einmal 1982, Ende 81, zehn Tage der Stille verbrachte und danach verrechnet
wurde  es ist wie eine musik wie ein
gedicht das kam zu mir ich fing an es zu
lehren ja klirren das macht eine
flitterwochen dahye metal verursacht
dir sogar von einar einar ein bunge bekehrter der
dringlichkeit das ist austin
ich will nicht sagen da draußen ist was
das bringt aber etwas tief
in mir, ich sehe, war Mission in Stuart
und ist kein klares Zuhause in DC Er gab jetzt,
ich bin Fort Lee nicht abgeneigt,
kein Interview zu haben, Schwestern, Mann, ich klickte auf die
Folie, so beliebtes Motto, aufgeregt  Wenn es
kafeel ist – lass ihn leben, kann er keine Pläne
über uns machen, da es wichtig ist, von uns zu sprechen
, und ein Prozentsatz weiß,
wie schlau diese vegane, einsame Seele ist.
Anfangs 18.000 Ritter, die sonst herauskamen.
Stan, nein, ich würde sehen, dass Schmerz
im Leben
unvermeidlich ist  Wenn Vergnügen kommt, kommt Schmerz, kommt der
Teil des Lebens, aber Leiden ist optional,
Ihr Geist kann sich an etwas festhalten und
die ganze Zeit daran kauen, was nicht
notwendig ist. Wenn also Weisheit vorhanden ist,
verlassen Sie die Vergangenheit, lernen aus der Vergangenheit, aber
Sie leben in der Vergangenheit  gegenwärtiger Moment sonst
was passiert Unser Geist oszilliert
zwischen Vergangenheit und Zukunft Wir sind wütend
über die Vergangenheit
Wir sind besorgt über die Zukunft und dies
verursacht so viele Giftstoffe in unserem
Körper, dass unsere ganze Idee darin besteht, die Vergangenheit zu vergeben und zu
vergessen, in der wir leben  im jetzigen
moment als martin weißt du anfangs
kann ich seinen eigenen mentalen ausweis nicht behalten es stand
geschrieben siehe ich bin finn ich freue mich über jeden
strebe bild die schwerkranke person
natürlich würde ich ihnen raten zum arzt zu gehen und medikamente zu
nehmen aber abgesehen davon  dass ich
sagen würde, stärken Sie Ihren Geist
durch Meditation durch
Atemübungen Sie sehen, dass ein starker Geist
einen schwachen Körper tragen kann, aber ein schwacher Geist kann nicht
mit einem starken Körper weitermachen, das müssen wir
verstehen, selbst wenn Ihr Geist schwach ist
Obwohl dein Körper stark ist, kannst du nicht
weitermachen, also ist mentale Stärke oder innere
Stärke sehr wichtig, das ist
ein einfacher Opportunist
Wenn ich in diese Analyse gehe, spreche ich NICHT davon, was ich sage - finden Sie auch die innere Stärke, mm-hmm, wenn
Leiden da ist, können Sie
das Leiden nicht einfach akzeptieren oder das Leiden genießen, aber
Sie müssen über das Thema hinausgehen, und es
ist möglich, dass andere er waren  Ein Clearin von
mir Tomkinson
Princip, so gestimmt, wie viele von Hindu
bereit sind, Kevin Kent, buddhistischer Elch, ja, der
Hinduismus-Buddhismus sprach definitiv
von Karma, Akarma, bedeutet Eindrücke
im Bewusstsein, es gibt einen Weg,
aus diesem Karma herauszukommen, also ist
Meditation der richtige Weg  darüber hinaus
etwas, um uns von Schmerzen zu befreien,
so sind sich heute sogar Wissenschaften darüber einig,
dass Sie diese Sache über
die Auswirkungen der Behandlung auf die Atmung wissen
Die schmerzhafte Auswirkung von Meditation auf das Gehirn,
also denke ich, dass es die Welt
verändert, verändert sich. Die Menschen akzeptieren es
Das kommt aus diesen
Praktiken einige es bringt einen mysteriösen Punkt
Nächster Punkt
Satya kann neun Stockwerke von Fadern
und zz9 Mode und Aufmerksamkeit verursachen Friedans
Phantom zu Ishika Food Eden nach Passieren
sogar Hinzufügen von Technik der Grundlage für
Meditation in kolumbianischen Lobbyisten, also
lasst uns 2015 und  Die Cosa Act-Maschine war
es, wenn sie mit Reiki ausgestattet sind. Zuhause
fazool Inkontinenz aus Holz. Gefühle für
Kokoschka
Positive Energie Sie wissen, dass die Leute
Ihnen zuhören und es wirkt sich auf eine Person aus, mit
der Sie sprechen, also würde ich sagen, es
ist die positive Energie  Energie und eine
Absicht, die sehr aufrichtig und mit
Liebe ist
- menschliche Berührung, du weißt, alles ist
möglich, das ist, was passiert ist. Ava ist ein
Manipulator und rollt oder zwei Werbespots
Alle fragen,
ich habe keine Ahnung, Thomas Monza, Konami, spielt
Kitty, und er will, dass wir männlich und
abgewaschen sind, und auf Tannaz war der Drucker
Mahans, obwohl ja, ich weiß, die ersten
drei Tage wissen Sie, am ersten Tag, als wir sie
trafen, zögerten sie, sie waren noch
nicht fertig  sich mit mir zu treffen, wie ich sehe
, es aus kolumbianisch zu lesen kuba kuba
zuerst zögerten sie, aber dann
kamen sie, um an meinem öffentlichen vortrag in der universität teilzunehmen,
dann kamen sie, um mich zu sehen, und
dann sprachen wir die nächsten drei tage und am
letzten tag kamen sie herauf  In dieser Phase
haben
sie mit mir eine Pressekonferenz angezogen und
sie sagten, einseitiger Waffenstillstand. Ich habe zugestimmt,
nein
ein Opfer in jedem
Täter, wenn wir dieses Opfer heilen,
verschwindet der Täter, und das ist, was
passiert, Sie wissen, dass wir
viele solcher Milizen in Indien transformiert haben, die
ihre Waffen fallen gelassen haben, um Gewaltfreiheit zum Mainstream zu machen,
wenn das unser Ziel ist, wissen Sie
das und wenn wir uns berühren  Dieser innere
Kern einer Person, die sie den
Ausdruck Jesus ändern, diese Invaliden
erwähnen Aufstände in
Geldbörsentrupps vollständig  und ich bin Latein
Kashyyyk
ja ja ja wir haben in
Gefängnissen auf der ganzen Welt unterrichtet wir haben
fast 800.000 Gefangene unterrichtet
, das ist also ein sehr klarer Beweis dafür, dass
Menschen, die zu Gefängnisstrafen verurteilt wurden,
eine Menschlichkeit in sich tragen
Wissen Sie, dass da eine gute Person
in ihnen sitzt, als wir diesen Arzt angezündet haben,
wissen Sie, dass sie auftauchen, also ja,
Schilling heißt so, richtig, wir haben versucht
, mit diesem Anführer einen Sinn zu machen
äh das hat damals irgendwie nicht geklappt
weil sie glaubten sie hätten
mehr militärmacht als für den
frieden aber leider gab es krieg
es war sehr traurig sache shalinka aber ich
habe mich bemüht die leute von union mann hertha´s dorthin zu bringen
Sein Auktionshaus
beendete alle Religionen, die
politisch getroffen wurden, als ein von Freiheiten gewürzter
Ausdruck des
Ereignisses. Friedans Konferenz im
ET des immer kürzeren Mid-Tempo-
Ministers Narendra Modi aus Pune hatte einen
Bauchschmerzen,
sesh, sein Outfit ist noch  nein, wenn
es große Konferenzen gibt, ist jeder
willkommen, es ist nicht nur eine einzige Partei
Treffen
aus der ganzen Welt und die 3,5
Millionen Menschen waren sie, also hat es
nichts mit Politik an sich zu tun. Ich
würde sagen, wir haben Programme in
Europa gemacht  Parlament, wir hatten keine Programme
in den USA.
Auf dem Capitol Hill haben wir viele
Programme durchgeführt, die von vielen Senatoren angesprochen wurden.
Sehen Sie, die Welt hat Demokratie. Sie hat vier
Säulen in dieser auf Glauben basierenden Organisation,
dann die Regierung, dann kennen Sie die
Geschäftshäuser und Medien, wenn sie
alle zusammenarbeiten, kann etwas Solides passieren,
ja, Nikita  in the Frog beziehen sich jetzt auf
wen die siebzig Politiker aus launischen
Alkanen der Analytik Testament Aheads
Relikt Yunnan auf Inder das höchste der
Muslime ein geheimes besonderes süchtig, dass
Evita val noch getroffen hat, also klopft mich die
Tatsache ab und wenn de Jemen Resilienz o
einen Zorn hervorrufen  Schaft bei dem Namen Modish
That und intimes Verständnis zerschmettert auf
Signal Sie wissen, dass ich niemanden unterstütze
in dem Konflikt zwischen den
Hindus und Muslimen, der 71 Jahre alt ist, wissen Sie,
der 400 500 Jahre alte Konflikt ist, also
kann ich selbst in dieser Hinsicht nichts sagen
Sache mit Politik und ich bin
wirklich ich kenne meinen Platz Ich bleibe
sehr neutral Ich lasse alle kommen und
wenn es einen Fehler gibt, stehe ich auf
und spreche dafür, dass jeder es tut Ich habe
keine Angst vor irgendjemandem, also wenn es eine Regierung gibt
oder irgendjemand sagte, macht etwas falsch, ich
erhob meine Stimme, ich kritisierte, ich sagte,
was richtig ist, ist nicht Claritin, geändert, die
Sprays und Koks, auf leer, keine Kolonie,
emittieren Antikörper ineinander
garten
und damit beladen auftrag ist arzt
alles klar
wenn ich fragen hätte dann würde ich nicht da
sitzen wo ich sitze fee notation
bank ernsthaft vielen dank
noch skeeters direkter kampf und bei indian
auf adams udan die verleumdungen berührten es
nämlich einen angriff  Verlorene Relikte Verwenden Sie stattdessen
Indus-Kontinente Geben Sie einer Täuschung eine Kilotonne
Shivas Meenakshi Eine Versicherung auf Reden Sie
über
[Musik]
Sie